mes chers collègues
si vous voulez prendre place s'il vous
plaît mes chers collègues nous allons
aujourd'hui procéder pour la première
fois à l'audition d'un membre envisagée
d'un président envisagée d'une
institution publique puisqu'il s'agit
aujourd'hui pour nous d'examiner là
candidature à la nomination de président
de radio france et monsieur jean luc est
ce ainsi que vous le savez c'est un des
pouvoirs nouveaux donné aux commissions
concernées en ce qui nous concerne et
avec nos homologues de l'assemblée
nationale la possibilité d'auditionner
le candidat à la présidence de radio
france à la suite de l'audition nous
devrons procéder à un vote où nous
répondrons cette question très simple
est ce que nous approuvons ou est-ce que
nous désapprouvons cette nomination nous
avons la possibilité de la désapprouver
à la majorité des trois cinquièmes des
votes de l'assemblée de la commission
saisie au fond à l'assemblée et au sénat
des deux commissions
pour votre information l'assemblée
nationale se réunira en ce qui la
concerne demain c'est aussi on se
déroule donc en application du dernier
alinéa de l'article 13 de la
constitution et de la loi organique du 5
mars 2009 relative à la nomination du
président de radio france et que et
comme nous l'avons souhaité cette
audition est publique
je souhaite donc la bienvenue à monsieur
est ce monsieur vous allez avoir
ils ont dix minutes un quart d'heure
pour nous exposer votre vos projets pour
l'avenir de radio france nous pourrons
ensuite vous poser un certain nombre de
questions
et puis nous procéderons au vote par
scrutin secret chaque membre présent ne
pouvant être muni que d'une procuration
voilà cher monsieur explosé douce cet
accueil veut être un petit peu solennel
mais maintenant ce qui compte c'est ce
que vous allez nous dire que le gros
projet à propos de radio france je vous
donne la parole
je vous en remercie monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je me présente devant vous
très conscients de l'importance de du
moment j'ai donc été désignés par
l'exécutif pour postuler à la présidence
de radio france
j'ai reçu l'avis conforme du csa et
selon cette nouvelle formule donc
instauré par la réforme la loi sur la
réforme de l'audiovisuel public
j'ai relu présente devant vous
aujourd'hui ce qui est j'en fais autant
demain donc devant vos collègues
l'assemblée ce qui est bien normal
puisque vous représenter la nation et
que je dis souvent que radio france
appartient à tous les français c'est
procédure entraîné je la veux je la veux
une légère difficulté celle de réserver
pendant plusieurs semaines maintenant
mon expression avoue sol donc jusqu'au
terme de cette désignation je suis donc
resté muet face à la curiosité de temps
en temps si la suspicion autour de
autour de cette nouvelle loi je suis
conscient de la responsabilité qui
m'incombe récit vous m'accordez votre
confiance en même temps que l'honneur de
diriger radio france bien sûr si vous le
permettez je vais m'autoriser à rompre
très partiellement la confidentialité
d'un entretien que j'ai eu avec le
président de la république et je crois
que cette relative indiscrétions est de
nature à répondre à une vraie question
de fond il ya quelques semaines donc le
président de naples icm a convié à
l'elysée il s'est enquis de mes
nouvelles activités il m'a demandé si
j'étais toujours passionnément épris de
l'industrie radiophonique et et aussi du
service public ce à quoi j'ai évidemment
répondu par l'affirmative et il m'a fait
savoir qu'il souhaitait désigné à la
tête de radio france un journaliste
je ne veux pas bien sûr interpréter la
pensée du président de la république
mais pour ma part j'ai lu son projet de
la manière suivante un journaliste dans
mon esprit et pas seulement dans mon
esprit un journaliste est un homme un
professionnel indépendant qui n'obéit
qu'à l'éthique de son métier président
la république au cours du même entretien
a constaté que nous ne nous connaissions
pas ce que je confirme devant vous mes
responsabilités président précédente mmm
ont conduit au fil des années par
déontologie à établir une sorte de
j'allais dire de barrage entre entre la
vie politique et moi quelle que soit
d'ailleurs les amitiés qu'on puisse
développer au cours des années ou en
tout cas les sympathies à moins encore
si vous le permettez sur cet entretien
avec le président de la république il a
précisé qu'il ne me demandez pas comment
j'avais voté j'ai apprécié la courtoisie
je vous le dis est plus important il m'a
fait savoir très solennellement que
jamais il ne me demanderait quoi que ce
soit qui puisse heurter la conscience ou
mes convictions lors à votre conviction
je ne pense pas qu'il s'agisse en la
circonstance de mai convient que nous de
mes préférences personnelles je suis un
citoyen comme les autres donc je vais
voter donc j'ai une option sur la vie
démocratique de ce pays mais ça ne
regarde que moi et mes intime et c'est
une règle que je me suis imposé dans mon
métier depuis bien longtemps
je vous disais que je suis un
professionnel de la radio donc mes
propres choix citoyens n'ont pas à être
mêlé à l'exercice de mon métier encore
mois l'exercice de mon éventuellement
d'un si encore une fois vous m'accordez
votre confiance j'ai en revanche des
convictions qui sont très très fortes
quant à l'exercice de ce mandat c'est
vrai que j'aspirais être président de
radio france et j'ai de cette mission de
service public une très haute idée est
depuis longtemps les français sont
justement attaché au service public
ces garants de l'égalité de traitement
pour tous est garante de la continuité
de ce service et c'est le garant d'un
développement services de la société
toute entière dans son pluralisme et sa
diversité gelé toujours compris comme ça
il est selon moi fondamental de défendre
en permanence est cette notion de
service public qui est une véritable
institution de la république et je ne
pense pas que je puisse être accusé de
grandiloquence en dix ans a parmi vous
il est selon moi vraiment fondamental de
défendre ce service public c'est pas une
notion anodine et j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire devant les membres
du csa
les antennes de la rive de la radio
publique appartiennent à tous les
français qu'ils soient de droite de
gauche du centre ou d'ailleurs qu'ils
soient jeunes ou moins jeunes qu'ils
soient favorisés ou moins favorisés
qu'ils aiment la pop music ou mozart et
c'est un service public que vous avez
constamment soutenu et aidé et c'est un
lien démocratique dont nous avons besoin
me semble-t-il encore plus à certains
moments de de l'actualité de ce pays
notamment quand on traverse une crise
j'ai dit que c'était une institution de
la république est encore un mot
là-dessus la république pour moi dans
mon domaine c'est d'abord l'accès de
tous à une information complète sérieuse
pluraliste et de qualité l'information
est le socle de la connaissance
citoyenne sur l'acte sur lequel on forge
on forge nous mêmes en fond de nos choix
individuel c'est particulièrement vrai
aujourd'hui où on a vu ses frites et
d'ailleurs de temps en temps la
confiance qu'on accorde à certaines
institutions certaine autorité
plus que jamais je pense que le citoyen
a besoin de ce socle d'informations sur
et vérifier qu'ils la base de la
connaissance politique commune de notre
société
c'est l'honneur des journalistes que de
participer ainsi un rôle essentiel dans
une démocratie moderne et je m'honore
que ce soit un journaliste que pourrait
être confiée la mission de conduire les
radios du service public et un
journaliste conscient de ses
responsabilités
la république c'est aussi à côté de
d'accès à l'information accès à la
culture bien sûr et au divertissement là
encore dans le respect du pluralisme de
toutes les recettes de la création bien
sûr radio france et vous savez est une
est en concurrence avec les groupes
privés c'est une excellente chose de mon
point de vue mais plus que jamais
service public doit faire entendre sa
différence
c'est différent c'est précisément cet
attachement à ces valeurs républicaines
et je suis d'ailleurs persuadé pour ma
part que cette différence est à l'heure
actuelle un vrai atout compétitif
alors aujourd'hui je dois par ce très
court exposé jouent leur met la
présentation de la vision pour radio
france sans un court exposé en quatre
points si vous le permettez donc sur les
antennes de radios de radio france sur
les relations sociales au sein de
l'entreprise
ils les travaux de réhabilitation de la
maison ronde et sur les nouvelles
technologies
je vais je vais aller vite pour pouvoir
répondre à vos questions radio france
dont vous le savez se distingue par la
spécificité et la diversité de ses
missions donc de ces antennes radio
france c'est près de 12 millions
d'auditeurs quotidiens sur cette chaîne
donc le groupe se porte plutôt bien
encore que il est enregistré de
meilleurs scores d'audience au début des
années 2000 je peux en témoigner
donc cette chaîne généraliste
thématiques ou de proximité quatre
formations musicales
c'est important parce que sur sur ce
groupe
ce groupe en feu environ 600
journalistes mais il emploie aussi de
façon régulière 400 musiciens
professionnels je parle pas des
comédiens et des services de comédiens
donc toutes ces entités sont
complémentaires bien sûr c'est le sens
d'un groupe de deux radios de service
public mais il me semble que cette
complémentarité pourrait fonctionner
mieux encore pour mieux me tuerait de
mutualiser les des ressources de
l'entreprise
comme dans toute industrie le paysage
radiophonique est en train de changer de
change et c'est tant mieux les habitudes
des coûts de nos auditeurs notamment des
plus jeunes ont beaucoup évolué on aura
sans doute l'occasion d'en parler ce
n'est qu'un début mais j'ai tendance à
penser que c'est une chance à la fois
pour nos antennes et pour nous et pour
nos productions
j'ai décrit devancé sa une de mes
priorités c'est le contenu des antennes
je crois qu'on peut toujours faire mieux
toujours aller plus loin toujours gagner
davantage auditeurs pour le service
public et ça s'appelle le progrès il
progresse et pas simplement dans la
technologie c'est une attitude le
progrès et aucune de nos antennes et
exemptes d'amélioration rapidement
france inter tient son rang dans dans
les radios généralistes mais elle a
connu des jours meilleurs en terme
d'audience en 2003 cette radio avait
atteint 11 8 % d'audience à des à 10,2
pour cent aujourd'hui je crois que là
aussi on peut mieux faire je crois que
l'érosion d'une antenne généraliste
n'est pas du tout une fatalité il faut
donc constamment rénové mobiliser les
antennes donc les personnels ce qui
n'est pas toujours très facile sur
france inter où sa veste une chaîne qui
a des auditeurs fusionnelle comme on dit
dans le métier je peux en parler
d'expérience donc il est difficile de
réformer certaines choses parfois il est
difficile de faire avancer les choses
parce que les gens qui nous écoutent son
son jeu un peu suspicieux quand on
introduit des changements sur une
antenne
ans interné palace à l'antenne comme ça
mais toute façon je pense qu'il faut
vraiment accompagner un peu plus la vie
des français moi j'ai certaines idées
évidemment de programme c'est bon c'est
bon métier de base je pense que ce sont
pas les personnels de france inter qui
se rebellent ray contre cette motion
d'avancé de stopper une érosion je crois
que c'est dans la nature de de nos
métiers d'essayer de de battre la
concurrence pour france info
j'ai assisté à la naissance de france
info il ya 22 ans donc ça reste
évidemment une référence très importante
pour moi je pense que c'est un outil de
grande qualité mais encore là le on sent
que les audiences stagne pour pour dire
le moins donc depuis quelques temps je
pense que là non plus ce n'est pas une
fatalité il ya toute une équipe
journalistique il ya vraiment
l'expérience qui a vraiment la
compétence et là je crois aussi qu'on
peut qu'on peut présenter des projets
nouveaux à une direction de chaîne et et
aux journalistes qui font cette équipe
est vraiment formidable je pense qu'il
faut refonder un certain nombre de
choses pour éviter
ne serait-ce que la répétitivité de de
l'antenne qui est y est enfin de son
automatisme je crois qu'à des non
vraiment de des choses nouvelles à
trouver et je crois que les personnels
franchement il ils sont prêts vont pas
rester les bras croisés en regardant
partir des parts de marché france bleu
c'est un comment dire c'est un modèle
dans son jardin mode si une radio enfin
qu'ils aient fait un groupe de radio qui
qui s'intéressent à la vie locale qui
sont ancrés dans la vie locale
mais c'est bien on sent très bien
content lorsque le pays traverse une
crise je pense aux intempéries
dernièrement une mobilisation des gens
qui est tout à fait extraordinaire un
vrai service et cette notion de service
est peut-être à faire revivre encore
davantage je pense aussi que les
personnels de de france bleu serait
attaché à sa faire vivre davantage les
services que peuvent rendre a dit aux
français une communauté encore une fois
surtout dans un moment de difficulté on
parle de difficultés économiques et
sociales
il ya des problèmes de couverture encore
sur ce réseau qui est très modernisée
qui est très dédié enfin c'est un très
beau réseau sur le plan technologique et
il ya encore des trous dans la
couverture de
de france bleu ce qui était un problème
récurrent par exemple la région midi
pyrénées se croient que c'est la plus
grande région de france d'ailleurs vécu
département et je pense que les
technologies nouvelles qui avancent
enfin conte dont on prévoit
l'utilisation serait de nature sûrement
à combler à combler un certain nombre de
trous de couverture ce qui serait
vraiment très très bien pour eux pour
france bleu france culture est une
station dont je parle peu que j'écoute
beaucoup parce que j'adore cette station
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire donc
je vous le répète mais je suis toujours
assez étonné par l'imagination et cette
espèce d'efforts de modernisme que fait
que fait france culture dans un monde
qui est ultra médiatique donc il ya une
démarche d'ouverture qui même qui me
plaît beaucoup et en plus on conserve la
france culture une espèce d'exigence
intellectuelle et c'est bien ça veut pas
dire que s'arrêter là france culture peu
importe qu'on remporte encore faire
beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts en termes de
d'ouverture et d'accessibilité un
certain nombre de public pour france
musique et on va je sais un peu de quoi
je parle en termes de concurrence
puisque puisque j'en viens donc il ya
cette concurrence mais france musique a
des atouts tout à fait unique je vais
pas parler des personnels de leur
culture mais un plus en plus de
l'ambition de france qu'une fente ile de
france musique qui n'est pas de
programme et toute la journée les tubes
de la musique savante donc il ya un vrai
projet qui est très important puis un
atout qui est tout à fait unique ce sont
les coûts formation musicale de radio
france
et je rappelle que france musique une
obligation si j'ose dire dans une un
cahier des charges qui n'existe pas mais
tout de même c'est de d'exposer nos
grandes formations musicales ce que
france musique fait moi je pense qu'on
peut encore faire davantage c'est vrai
que france musique diffuse je crois 600
concerts par an c'est le slogan est vrai
c'est plus la plus grande salle de
concert du monde mais je pense qu'on
peut tout on peut toujours mieux faire
pour nos formations et je pense que ce
propos vaut aussi pour d'autres antennes
une antenne comme france inter alors
qu'il le fait dans l'émission de
programme il me sens qu'on devrait
exposer davantage là le talent et la
beauté de nos formations musicales
je vais vous dire un mot sur le move
aussi qui est une une radio qui
m'intéresse beaucoup de bas possibles
futures perspectives
c'était une c'est une très belle idée de
service public parce qu'il ya le marché
d'à radio il ya les parts de marché
qu'on entend conquérir il ya le souci
qu'on peut avoir aussi de devoir
l'érosion des auditeurs jeunes des
chaînes de radio france peut-être à
l'exception de france mme d'ailleurs mai
mais au-delà de tout ça au delà de
l'industrie radiophonique il ya le fait
que ça c'est une mission de service
public de s'intéresser à ce public jeune
quand on a vraiment besoin et le public
jeune de mon point de vue c'est pas
simplement un public que un peu perdu et
avide de musique de son époque ça doit
aller un petit peu au-delà de ça et
quand on regarde le move je pense d'une
position de critiquer ce serait trop
facile je pense je suis dans une
position où je me demande comment on
peut améliorer les choses sensiblement
pour des antennes
je dis qu'il faut revoir un certain
nombre de choses qu'il faut où il faut
ça veut pas être un ghetto une radio de
jeunes il faut qu' il ya des formats
d'information pour les jeunes il faut
intégrer fou et d intégrer des gens dont
jane dans une communauté dont ils
comprennent pas toujours tous les
mécanismes et on ne peut pas leur
reprocher et donc moi je pense qu'il
faut s'attarder davantage dans le
contenu d anthony faut revoir des choses
et il faut ouvrir cette radio un public
plus large
il faut s'intéresser à l'éveil culturel
à l'éveil artistique faut s'intéresser à
l'éveil politique aussi de des jeunes
français et donc je crois qu'il y à
vraiment l'un des chantiers eux si ce
n'est imposant mais un chantier vraiment
tout à fait tout à fait passionnant
parce que j'ai regardé les chiffres de
médiamétrie sur cinq ans
le groupe radio france et antennes de
radio france ont perdu 20% de leur
public jeune aaron il faut aussi être
objectif et voir que l'accès à nos anta
n'est pas évident pour pour les publics
jeunes en soi mais tout de même je pense
que l'on peut parler c'est tombé ça
comme ça un tout petit mot sur fip si
vous le permettez
c'est un bijou j'ai démarré ma carrière
radiophonique le vix mars 1972 c'est
vous dire que c'est une radio que je
regarde avec beaucoup d'intérêt moi je
pense qu'une priorité de du futur
président de radio france c'est
d'élargir la diffusion de fip enfin je
veux dire on peut pas se dire qu'on a
très très beau produit et le dire sans
arrêt puis nous reste est resté à ce
statu quo il ya des petits problèmes par
là et je pense qu'au delà aussi les
technologies d'aujourd'hui pourrait nous
permettre d'améliorer la diffusion de
fip soit par la modulation de fréquence
en partie soit ainsi par le parlement
internet je crois que c'est un des sites
et plus les plus visités de de radio
france j'en ai fini avec les antennes je
répondrais bien sûr à vos questions un
point important sur les relations
sociales au sein du duo radio france est
une maison qui compte près de 4500
personnes et la masse salariale compte
pour près de 60% du budget de
l'entreprise
il se trouve que l'arrivée d'un nouveau
président à la tête de ce groupe
coïncide avec la dissolution du de
l'association des employeurs de
l'audiovisuel public
suite au retrait de france télévisions
alors du coup ce qui est cohérent
d'ailleurs d'une certaine façon même si
le timing est un petit peu plus
difficile du coup un peu plus abrupte
mais les conventions collectives
régissant la vie des salariés de radio
france deviennent donc caduque et je
comprends les inquiétudes du personnel
surtout surtout en cette période il faut
donc vais écrire cette convention
collective on n'a pas le choix du
calendrier encore une fois on a quinze
mois devant nous pour arriver à
renégocier cette convention qui peut
être une chance pour tout le monde aussi
bien pour l'entreprise que pour les
personnels de
en france puisque on arrive dans une
période de deux nouveaux métiers donc
dans notre activité
donc c'est cohérent avec l'évolution de
nos métiers
ce serait évidemment ma priorité est de
fixer un calendrier de négociations tout
de suite avec les organisations
syndicales de la maison je rappelle que
les précédentes conventions collectives
qui régissent la vie de radio france en
ce moment date de mars 1984 donc ça fait
plus de 25 en un quart de siècle les
choses ont changé depuis et plusieurs
parlementaires des sénateurs notamment
ont rappelé cette nécessité au fil des
années on vraiment prêché pour la
modernisation nécessaire deux de ses
textes
individuellement j'ai le sentiment que
les salariés du groupe radio france sont
prêts il ya des inquiétudes mais je sens
qu'ils sont prêts qu'ils sont conscients
de la nécessité de réévaluer ses textes
collectivement il n'empêche cadre pour
en discuter donc ce serait à moi y'a mon
équipe de fournir ce cadre et et encore
une fois je
je sens que les choses ont beaucoup
évolué au sein de cette maison que je
connais bien
au final il s'agit d'adapter je voulais
les entreprises à des à des nouveaux
métiers mobiles assurer un cadre
protecteur ou s'est ralliée de radio
france est une maison qui sera les
formes et qui sera les accompagner qui
sera assuré leur propre développement en
termes de compétences et de promotion et
la discussion générale début très bien
sûr immédiatement troisième et avant
dernier sujet si vous le permettez la
réhabilitation de la maison ronde alors
vous vous connaissez ce dossier c'est un
sujet majeur parce que parce que en
dépend la sécurité des personnels de
radio france en dépend l'activité de la
maison ronde et et en dépend des deniers
publics aussi alors ces travaux étaient
nécessaires bien sûr pour assurer la
sécurité incendie nécessaire aussi de
façon opportuniste pour moderniser nos
installations et rendent les rendre plus
fonctionnel à la fois pour les salariés
pour le pour le public
le coût total croît est estimé à 420
millions d'euros
en euros courants en euros constants
pardon soit sensiblement plus que les
prévisions énoncées par le contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens
en tout cas d'après le bilan performance
établie par la ddm en 2007
vu de l'extérieur et je suis à
l'extérieur je n'ai pas connaissance du
dossier
c'est un dossier à risque comme la
plupart des chantiers de cette amplitude
bien sûr je crois que le rapporteur
spécial du sénat monsieur claude bellot
se montrer assez critiques l'an dernier
sur un certain nombre de points quant à
la conduite des opérations
on me dit que le budget a été revu à la
baisse alors est-ce qu'il s'agit du même
projet ce que certains éléments de
rénovation ont été abandonnées je n'ai
pas accès aux dossiers encore une fois
mais évidemment une vigilance exemplaire
s'imposent 1 un mot pour terminer sur
les nouvelles technologies qui sont en
train de révolutionner nos métiers
l'enjeu est évidemment vital pour pour
radio france qu'il s'agisse des outils
numériques ou du web
la convergence des médias des
télécommunications et de l'informatique
c'est une réalité comprise par tous les
acteurs du marché un pas seulement à
radio france
dans quel site web de mai nous intéresse
il ya d'abord la production numérique la
diffusion numérique et puis depuis
internet en ce qui concerne la
production numérique je crois qu'on peut
dire qu'elle est entrée dans les moeurs
de l'âme de la maison je savais même
obtenu il ya cinq ans lors du
déménagement de france inter la
numérisation totale des moyens de
production donc les personnels sont
vraiment se sont vraiment assouplies et
c'est vraiment un métier d'ailleurs
qu'ils adorent bien sûr la diffusion
numérique nous amène à cette fameuse
radio numérique terrestre la rnt c'est
notre avenir c'est même notre destin
puisque puisqu'à terme ce sera notre
mode de diffusion
actuellement la diffusion de programmes
se fait sur le modèle analogique à mais
on l'a vu les fréquences sont rares la
rnt dont une formidable opportunité que
cette maison ne peut pas on peut pas
rater bien sûr ça permet de servir tout
le monde
la qualité du son est meilleur
ça permet de d'enrichir nos programmes
de produits associés puis ça permet
aussi de à terme de baisser nos coûts de
diffusion jeudi à terme parce que la
question importante c'est de savoir
combien de temps il y aurait que
l'existence au fur et à mesure du
développement de la rnt comme un temps
il y aurait coexistence avec la
modulation de fréquence parce que ça
augmente sensiblement les coûts
diffusion point haut comme radio france
donc cette question de de la mise en
place du temps nécessaire à la mise en
place est importante on peut penser
généralement c'est à dire est peut-être
plus vite que beaucoup de gens disaient
si on regarde le succès de la tnt ou de
l'adsl donc tous les historiques de la
télévision qui sont qui ont négligé la
tnt s'en mordent aujourd'hui les doigts
donc évidemment c'est un rendez vous
capital pour pour un groupe comme radio
france
j'ai gardé internet pour la fin le net
qui introduit une relation alors que
tout à fait nouvelle entre le diffuseur
et l'auditeur j'allais dire que le web
est devenu le meilleur ami de la radio
puisque les gens tiennent la radio dans
la mobilité aussi donc c'est un couple
qui fait qu'il fait bon ménage qui va se
développer
près d'un tiers près d'un tiers des
européens écoutent leurs programmes de
radio par l'intermédiaire du web ce qui
est dit quelque chose ce même sur sur
l'avenir sur ce plan là je dois dire que
radio france a su s'adapter
voire mieux
le service l'équipe multimédia de radio
france parle de 80 millions de podcasts
par an donc ce qui est considérable et
là le champ d exploration est très très
vaste il faut il faut les explorer avait
un moment de silence gardé la tête
froide aussi devant toutes les
opportunités pour un groupe comme
comment radio france ça peut permettre
d'apporter beaucoup de complémentarité à
l'antenne ça peut ça favorise évidemment
l'interactivité et la relation avec nos
auditeurs
ça peut permettre la co production de
contenu ça peut permettre aussi
d'imaginer des services si je dis payant
vous gratuit jusque là vous n'aurez pas
la mémoire trop trop trop sélectif sur
ce sur ce sujet on est allé très loin
d'ailleurs déjà ailleurs dans d'autres
pays dans ce domaine je pense à 6 à 9
ans devra par exemple aux états unis qui
permet qui proposent par ordinateur les
morceaux les plus génétiquement proches
de vos goûts il ya aussi des radios le
cobp sirius à inventer des des radios
pas d'enchaîner radio sinatra aux états
unis donc sinatra les couleurs un tir
dans 124 de quoi vous rendre la vie très
indigeste si enfin lorsqu'une conscience
ça serait plutôt comme ça je préfère
jazzafip mais en tout cas c'est pas tout
à fait dans ce sens là que j'imagine
l'avenir du d'avenir des antennes et des
marques de radio france je crois que le
service public doit privilégier l'offre
à la demande et et
dans ces contenus pour le web
privilégiez la culture et la
connaissance il ya vraiment un océan
devant nous je pense simplement à ce
qu'on pouvait faire d'une plateforme de
partage des connaissances avec les
enseignants et leur classe ça pourrait
être aussi dans les futurs métiers de
radio france de là ma vision express
bien sûr un pool et pour les uns cana
qui viennent si si je devenais président
de radio france
ça suppose une mobilisation générale des
antennes donc des personnels à chaque
fois que radio france que l'entreprise
radio france a entrepris et la réussite
je vous remercie de votre votre
attention je suis à votre disposition
version pour vos questions merci
monsieur je vais tout de suite de faire
la paix la question monsieur la gauche
qui est notre représentant au conseil
d'administration à vos priorités
écoutez monsieur c'est avec grand
plaisir que je vous ai écoutés et
entendus
vous nous avez même fait des confidences
du président ce qui nous a intéressé
dans la mesure où il a dit qu'ils ne
vous demanderai jamais rien je pense qu
il a ajouté qu'ils peuvent ou révoqué du
jour au lendemain
c'est un point qui n'est pas négligeable
dans le débat que nous avons eu lors de
mes problèmes de désignation des gens de
télévision des gens de radio notre pain
quand je vous entends je ne sais pas si
en définitive vous êtes là des candidats
à la présidence que l'on doit choisir et
vous nous donner votre point de vue sur
la radio ce qu'on voyait l'évolution des
choses et c'est aussi c'est une
introduction à un cahier des charges
qu'on vous a remis et vous nous dit il
bien voilà comment je vais aborder ce
cahier des charges
j'ai l'impression que ce n'est ni l'un
ni l'autre que
nous sommes ici par notre bonne volonté
pour vous entendre
mais en aucun cas nous pourrons vous
faire des remarques sur vos propositions
puisque vous n'êtes pas les signé et
comme nous n'avons pas qu'on charge de
vous aider désigné mais simplement de
récuser éventuellement la proposition du
président de la république vous doutez
bien que pour nous en tous les cas
groupe de position la situation n'est
pas facile dans la mesure où évidemment
par rapport à vous vont rien contre vous
a priori mais il nous paraît être à
difficile de nous prononcer sur le choix
du président dans la mesure où nous
sommes pas d'accord sur la modalité qui
a été adopté par la majorité
par le gouvernement en fait soutenu par
à sa majorité
bien qu'au sénat nous ayons fait des
propositions un petit peu différente qui
n'ont pas été reprises par la commission
mixte mais bon c'est comme ça
nous nous trouvons dans une situation
tout à fait ambiguë nous sommes venus en
séance par courtoisie vis-à-vis de vous
et bien entendu le jour où vous serez
désigné s'effarer grand plaisir je
suppose que notre commission vous
écoutera sur vos objectifs en fonction
du cahier des charges que vous ne
manquerez pas de nous exposer et à
partir de là nous pourrons vous
interroger et peut-être vous faire vous
faire des propositions ou des
suggestions
je comprends votre point de vue monsieur
sénateurs simplement je dois être dans
cette salle le plus mal placé pour
commenter cette loi de réforme de la loi
sur l'audiovisuel
j'espère vous me comprenez permets moi
permettez-moi de rajouter je ne sais pas
si vous êtes angoissé sur le résultat du
vote
compte tenu de l'intérêt que vous portez
effectivement à cette désignation
et si le vote qui va s'écrouler vous
angoisse a priori et si vous le jugez
utile oui vraiment je suis jeune et dans
une perspective sûrement différente de
la vôtre monsieur sénateurs mais bien
sûr que le résultat de de ce bac
m'angoisse musique j'aspirais à devenir
président de radio france donc c'est pas
une formalité je n'ai jamais pensé je
vous demande 2 de croire en la sincérité
de mon propos que les
représentant de la nation était là pour
enregistrer une décision déjà prise donc
j'ai cherché à vous convaincre de ma
capacité à devenir président de radio
france
monsieur renard a demandé la parole oui
merci monsieur le président moi je
voudrais simplement dire aussi que nous
sommes là réunis dans un processus
inédit bien évidemment quoi avec ce qui
concerne la aussi moi aussi pas
totalement à l'aise par rapport à la
perte à votre personne monsieur est bien
évidemment je suis un vieil auditeurs de
radio france et de pas toutes les
chaînes payer 20 de france inter de
france musique enfin b et puis donc que
j'ai été aussi votre auditeurs et j'ai
applaudi et toussus réjouit souvent à
vous écouter
alors ce cas c'est que le mode de
désignation par le président de la
république effectivement
pose problème donc son espèce de porte à
faux
il rejoint un peu ce que disait serge
serge lagauche
il ya moins un problème du point de vue
de la méthode parce que c'est vrai que
on avait avancé des propositions ici au
sénat on pouvait aller dans les deux
sens dans le processus de nomination de
l'un à vide aussi dans le processus de
blocs éventuellement le processus de
démission d'office enfin de révocation
oui enfin bon
alors j'avais quand même une petite
question à vous poser c'est le vous avez
été l'artisan d'une certaine forme
d'insolence sur sur france inter
l'insolence tranquille j'appellerai
tranquille mais une véritable solans est
ce que vous pensez toujours que l'as
olemps l'impertinence sont des valeurs
de la démocratie est peut-être encore
une question mais veut parler non plus
parce qu'on on sera amené à vous revoir
vraisemblablement même très sûrement
on pourra vous posez des questions sur
virement le votre programme entre
parenthèses
radiophonique et vous êtes leur le mode
d'industrie radiophonique et 1000 mhz
est vrai jamais abordé dans votre cour
exposer les problèmes de son de la radio
phonique et donc de la place de l'art et
de la culture sur sur le service public
de la radio qu'à ses formes à lui des
formes originales bien évidemment alors
je vais retirer c'est ce vilain mot je
dirais activités radiophoniques je pense
que vous avez raison ce qui concerne 2
le service public je sais pas si je suis
j'étais insolent aussi j'ai incarné une
certaine insolence en tout cas je suis
sûr que dans mon métier j'ai essayé
d'être libre je croyais être parvenu
dans mes limites à moi dans ma morale à
moi dans ma je suis journaliste monsieur
le sénateur de temps en temps ça m'a
coûté cher mon indépendance se dire j'ai
payé le prix personne n'en a jamais
entendu parler je ne me suis pas plaint
je connais les règles et il m'est arrivé
de quitter la maison radio france
c'était peut-être aussi une façon de
payer le prix de cette liberté en tout
cas su ni vertige assuré pour toutes les
équipes j'ai fait constamment je sais
pas c'est une affaire d'éducation c'est
une affaire de morale si c'est une
affaire d'expérience professionnelle
mais j'ai toujours défendues musée qui
contre toute pression d'ailleurs souvent
elle n'était même pas au courant des
éventuelles pressions qui prouvé qu'il
pouvait y avoir je suis pas un homme
naïf ça fait 40 ans que je fais ce
métier et donc j'ai eu l'occasion de
saisir la complexité des relations entre
le médiatique et politique
seulement j'ai eu l'habitude d'assumer
mes responsabilités
pourquoi voudriez vous que je commence
une dites-nous carrière de dictateur à
57,1
mais je vous dis ça c'est pas une
boutade c'est à dire que c'est peut-être
une affaire de caractère ou plutôt de
principe et les gens qui me connaissent
au sein de radio france afin savent que
il ya c'est pas facile de diriger un coq
ya toujours de la pression il ya
toujours même une antenne simplement à
france inter avec 453 personnes alors
j'essaie de me retirer de ce tropisme
france inter c'est une partie de ma vie
mais donc ce n'était pas toujours des
moments faciles c'est une chaîne via
d'information il ya de l'humour de
l'impertinence c'est vrai que je suis
pas fana du slogan si vous voulez mais
c'est une question sémantique c'est pas
une question polémique
humour plus intelligence ça suffirait à
mon bonheur de deux patrons de radio
france il devenait patron de radio
france vous voyez je crois que parfois
on est dépassé par par les polémiques
d'une d'une antenne et je pense à
stéphane guillon par exemple dont on a
beaucoup parlé
je suis bien convaincu le connaissant
bien le connaissant de prêt qui s'est
trouvé dépassé par la polémique qui
était créé tout à coup et ne laissez pas
ce sont des se sont comment dire des des
sujets qu'on peut aborder sur une
antenne qu'on peut aborder au sein d'une
équipe on peut on peut régler beaucoup
de choses simplement
il y a des ya des bases de comportement
quand on travaille sur une antenne de
service public et je changerai jamais
d'avis là dessus j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de dire publiquement au csa la
diffamation mais totalement
insupportable je le sais parce que j'ai
eu à y répondre en tant que patron
d'antenne et qu'un patron d'antenne est
responsable de ses équipes diam's est
pas les boucs émissaires les gens ne
donc d'une antenne
ils ont un patron qui les dirigent sinon
c'est pas la peine d'avoir un patron
donc moi je l'assumé ces choses là je ne
supporte pas diffamation je supporte pas
le mensonge je supporte pas l'injure à
part ça on peut être humoristique est
très intelligent il ya beaucoup de marge
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de marge donc je
vous demande s'il vous plaît de me faire
confiance et pas vous inquiéter sur la
liberté la tolérance la censure l'humour
on vit dans un monde moderne on a besoin
de se détendre c'est moi qu'on puisse
y compris moi d'ailleurs devant vous
donc voila quoi je serai pas un assassin
évidemment évidemment je ne suis pas au
bout de quarante ans de métier risqué ma
réputation sur eux sur ce genre de
soupçons
alors monsieur thiollière qui est notre
rapporteur médias qui m'a morin desailly
qui a été co rapporteurs juline que vous
avez des questions à poser puisque
d'auge qui m'a demandé la parole merci
monsieur le président je voudrais
monsieur est composé de trois types de
questions si vous voulez bien
premier à première question la cour des
comptes avait demandé imaginer que l'on
puisse avoir un contrat d'objectif et
moyens pour piloter radio france et donc
monsieur cluzel s'est beaucoup inspiré
peinture ce contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens qui vient à terme cette année et
donc c'est intéressant si vous disiez
comment vous verriez vous même si vous
accédez donc la présidence de radio
france
le contenu de ce contrat d'objectifs et
de moyens qu'ils en seraient les
évolutions vous souhaiteriez et puis
bien sûr la clé financière qui va avec
comment souhaiteriez vous voir évoluer
le budget de radio france et à supposer
que l'on vous demande de faire des
économies ce qui est dans l'air du temps
pour tout un chacun aujourd'hui comment
verriez-vous la gestion de ce contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens
le deuxième type de questions c'est sur
une façon de voir les programmes des
différentes antennes de radio france
si on imagine que vous souhaitez y est
allé plus loin dans par exemple
l'élargissement des programmes de france
musique dont vous parliez tout à l'heure
il ya une sorte d'équilibré trouvé entre
élargissement des programmes et
l'audience qu'on est capable d'obtenir
ou qui est possiblement en train de se
rétrécir si on changeait programme
parlait d'ailleurs de fusion entre les
auditeurs et les antennes ce qui est
sûrement très vrai et donc il ya des
risques à prendre et donc à quel endroit
verrier roule curseur pour des chaînes
ou présentés dans l'occurrence du
service public du troisième type de
questions c'est un service public et ce
sont les antennes service public et donc
il ya un problème d'équité territoriale
bull rapide tout à l'heure avec radio
bleue on est un certain nombre de
collègues de nos territoires à ne pas
avoir de couverture du service public de
radio france sur nos territoires nous
pensons que cela est injuste au sens
républicain du terme parce que le
service public doit couvrir la totalité
des territoires et apporter à la fois la
formation mais aussi les moyens de débat
démocratique qui soit le même partout
quand on lit partout c'est que cela
représente effectivement des régions qui
sont de plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'habitants voient plusieurs millions
d'habitants et de la même manière comme
leur valeur il y a on a la chance
d'avoir avec radio france des des
orchestres de grande qualité
malheureusement ces orchestres sont très
parisien de par leur leur fonctionnement
et de parjure et la richesse de la
programmation est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer dans l'avenir que ces
orchestres là puissent aussi jouer un
rôle de moteur sur les territoires de
notre pays
trois types édition que j'aimerais
pouvoir vous posez j'ai commencé par la
musique si vous le voulez bien je
travaille actuellement chez un
compétiteur de de france musique et je
vous fais une confidence j'ai découvert
un monde assez assez fantastique dans
les musiciens classiques je connaissais
moins bien que que la culture dit dites
populaires dans mes activités de patron
d'antenne à france inter et je suis
tombé de patients pour ces gens là et je
pense que c'est
ces gens là il ya une génération tout à
fait étonnante où il ya une fantaisie
une envie de faire je ne retrouve pas
dans d'autres secteurs culturels
forcément et j'étais très surpris par sa
et et ça m'a donné beaucoup d'idées
enfin on peut rêver mais après comme
vous me parlez des moyens et du budget
de radio france mais il faut peut-être
pas que je rêve trop sinon on va entrer
en contradiction avec votre propos votre
propos précédents mais les formations
les deux les deux orchestres de radio
france sont à niveau devenu vraiment est
exceptionnel je trouve et moi je pense
comme vous je pense que il ya plein
d'occasions où ces formations pourraient
sortir de paris il ya de beaux endroits
aussi pour donner des concerts en france
et je je pense aussi à d'autres choses
parce que je me suis beaucoup intéressé
récemment ces derniers mois à la
démocratisation des publics de la
musique classique
si vous avez des enfants
la pratique musicale en france auprès
des jeunes se développe de façon assez
étonnante et si vous avez des enfants
c'est très compliqué les inscrire un
conservatoire ou une école de musique
il ya une vraie demande et moi c'est
vrai que j'ai des rêves un peu fou avec
les orchestres de la maison c'est que
c'est vrai que mercredi après midi mais
c'est une idée que j'avais déjà à voir
mais c'est toujours difficile de faire
mes choses mais on peut le faire on ne
scie si on veut on peut faire des choses
quand on a des outils pareil à
disposition mercredi après midi j'ai
toujours rêvé d'avoir un embouteillage
de cars scolaires dans la maison d'un
radio que tout le monde enfin que tous
ces enfants qui volent
lisez la possibilité d'accéder à sa qui
découvre un monde qui connaissent pas
moi j'ai eu cette chance à radio france
il m'est arrivé d'aller dans les stades
de répétition ou de m'asseoir enfin de
mettre à côté du chef pourrait coûter un
orchestre ce que je n'avais jamais
entendu de ma vie j'ai attendu d'avoir
45 ans pour ça j'ai trouvé ça
merveilleux donc c'est un des alors je
veux pas m'avancer trop parce que après
faut faire bouger beaucoup de choses
sont des mondes merveilleux et délicat
mais je pense que oui il ya une il faut
faire quelque chose par là je vais botté
en touche sur une question c'est à dire
si vous permettez c'est sur le contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens parce que je
n'ai pour l'instant accès à aucun
dossier de radio france donc il m'est
difficile j'ai une idée globale des
budget génie des global de la masse
salariale par exemple j'ai donc comme
vous me parler par exemple de la
couverture de france bleu je me dis que
là aussi on risque d'être en
contradiction parce que j'aimerai vous
voir pour m'aider à avoir des mois des
moyens budgétaires supplémentaires parce
que moi je pense que france butin et
fait partie de ce service public c'est
un lien absolument essentiel en plus il
ya beaucoup de choses à y faire en
termes de développement des services
locaux et donc je me battrai pour ça
mais je serai obligé de venir vous voir
monsieur sénateurs pour vous demander un
peu de ma peu dead est donc encore une
fois sur ce qui concerne le contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens c'est un c'est
un dossier vital pour la maison pour les
années qui viennent et qui doit être
remis enfin mis sur le sur le métier
dans deux mois trois mois maintenant ils
arrivent à expiration je crois le 1er
juillet donc je me permet de réserver
mes réponses le mourant de faillite puis
monsieur d'auge ainsi monsieur le
président dans quelques questions
complémentaires à ce que vient de dire
mon collègue michel thiollière peut-être
pour rebondir sur france bleu puisqu'on
vient de terminer sur ce sur ce sujet je
crois qu'on peut dire que france bleu et
un peu à radio france que france 3 est à
france télévisions la loi sur
l'audiovisuel a été l'occasion de
réfléchir assez profondément au rôle de
cette chaîne de ça sa spécificité et je
crois pouvoir dire que notre souci était
tout même de leur affirmer son rôle
particulier pour pour les pour les
régions alors ma question est là et la
suivante en fait elle complète celle de
michel thiollière c'est jugez-vous à
titre personnel que la part de
programmes locaux dans leur diversité
vous avez évoqué la couverture de la de
la tempête mais dans leur diversité est
globalement satisfaisant qui répondent
aux besoins bien sûr des des populations
donc ça c'est ma première question en
matière de public vous avez évoqué la
nécessaire diversification des publics
notamment à destination des jeunes
avez vous donc une idée de création
d'indicateurs spécifiques qui
permettrait de juger aller au delà des
chiffres que l'on obtient va bien sûr
médiamétrie mais cette fois des
indicateurs spécifiques qui permettrait
de juger de la qualité du service rendu
au public par le groupe
autre question concernant cette fois le
monopole
de la mobilité de la gratuité qui avec
le développement de l'internet
aujourd'hui mais demain la télévision
mobile personnelle va forcément se
renforcer quel peut-être justement
l'apa est très particulière et son
avenir de la radio dans ce paysage qui
maintenant est constitué de deux
nouveaux supports très attractif
notamment d'ailleurs pour pour les
jeunes ça c'est un véritable défi
certainement qui vient à relever alors
je commençais par france bleu c'est
comment dire
j'ai eu l'impression discutant ici ou là
c'est ainsi qu' il y avait une
centralisation très importante à france
2 c'est à dire qu'il ya une organisation
qui est devenu très centralisé très très
parisienne en fait et je crois qu'il vit
des temps c'est à étudier il faut
discuter avec les personnels
encore une fois ce sont des gens très
dédiés alors à leur mission je crois
qu'il faut il faut peut être voir ça
pourrait peut-être libérée quelques
initiatives par là justement pour pour
permettre peut-être une quand plus
grande diversité enfin de donner la
place qui revient d'ailleurs c'est dans
cahier des charges de france de la
diversité de nos régions je crois que
plus je sens une envie de ça je sens une
envie de ça dort dans les personnes je
veux parler très souvent des personnes
parce que la radio cd personnel c'est
essentiellement ce sont des gens qui
fabriquent des antennes ne s'est pas
france télévisions nous tout est
internalisé
donc il faut si on veut faire avancer
des choses si on veut faire avancer des
contenus c'est faut convaincre il faut
mobiliser les légendes et un thème dont
je pense que il ya des parts de marché à
gagner' pardonnez-moi encore mais je
suis aussi moins comptable si j'étais
présidente de radio france si je vous
parle de marché si je vous parle de part
d'audience ces choses là c'est pas anti
service public c'est pour le service
public c'est à dire un service public ça
va être forcée a gardé des auditeurs
plus il en a 16 public plus il est fort
ce service public donc je crois qu'à des
parts de marché à prendre sur sur ce
créneau parce que enfin si haut sur ce
chapitre france bleu parce que france
bleu c'est très moderne comme réseau
c'est très très bien fait et donc depuis
une dizaine d'années c'est entre six et
sept points d'audience donc ciani en
plus la vie démocratique de nos régions
en dépend beaucoup je vois ça dans la
région dans la région provence côte
d'azur par exemple c'est quand comme
c'est fou comme les radios le débat
politique par exemple existent sur les
radios de france le sait vraiment je
crois très important enfin c'est pas
vous que je vais dire ça je vais pas
vous convaincre de samé mais c'est
vraiment très important en jv un petit
peu dans le désordre c'est parce que
c'est un point que je voulais que je
voulais souligner g je passe à la
qualité un fan indices qualitatif de nos
programmes
moi j'ai tendance à penser que les
patrons antennes sont des gens qui
seraient d'instituts de qualitatif
voiliers qui ont l'oreille qui ont qui
savent on sait tout de même assez
précisément ce qu'on offre aussitôt
qualifiée aussi c'est pas la qualité
j'ai tendance à penser que c'est le
métier de chacun à la radio donc je je
voit pas trop quel genre d'instrument
qualitatif je pouvais avoir à part
l'audience a laissé c'est formidable
audience on sait quand on écoute la
radio on sait si on monte aussi en
baisse dans les sondages et je vous jure
que c'est vrai sur quelques jours on se
dit tiens là cette radio n'est pas en
forme
elle va baisser dans les sondages tant
que ce n'est pas un peu prétentieux mais
cesser toutes ses années de pratique qui
me font dire ça je suis pas le seul dans
la maison de radio france à à sentir les
choses comme ça et puis j'ai peur
d'avoir oublié la dernière question est
posée parce que j'ai oublié mon stylo
j'ai pas pu le noter le monopole de la
mobilité la gratuité en fait des
supports aujourd'hui je n'ai plus la
radio avec la l'internet et la
télévision mobile personnelle demain la
radio doit trouver sa place dans ce
paysage qu'elle peut-elle être madame c
vous savez il ya le la consommation
globale de radio en ce moment elle est
aux alentours de 80 3%
c'est il ya plus de juifs français sur
10 qui écoutent la radio et déjà la
pénétration d'internet la concurrence
d'internet en termes d'information par
exemple c'est déjà extraordinaire et
c'est pas fini donc bien sûr qu'il faut
garder ça en tête mais moi je trouve ça
sain médias qu'un très très bonne santé
c'est pas le cas dans tous les pays aux
etats-unis par exemple en ce moment
parce que justement les virages sont pas
bien pris parce que parce qu'on internet
a tout mangé d'un coup culturellement et
s'est pas encore tout à fait le cas je
crois en français c'est à nous
d'accompagner d'ailleurs c'est à dire
que c'est à nous de faire vivre ces deux
médias au bénéfice de la radio mais il y
aura aussi d'autres d'autres intrusion
il y aura l'intrusion de l'écrit à la
radio fatalement dur à l'intrusion de
l'image je pense à l'écrit parce que je
pense à fip
je pense à se masser ce service
d'actualités culturelles de fip qui faut
à tout prix alors régénérer pour le coup
il y aura un moment dans les données
associées d'une
d'une radio il ya de l'écrit fayyad il
ya des métiers il ya plein de nouveaux
métiers qui sont en train de se profiler
et moi j'ai totalement confiance dans
l'avenir de la radio si un groupe comme
le nôtre d'ailleurs jeudi un groupe
comme radio france mais c'est vrai de
tous les groupes privés de radio à eux
ils sont tous en train d'imaginer les
mêmes choses et de voir comment personne
n'accepte cette érosion des audiences au
profit d'un autre mode d'information
donc je suis pas réputé pour être féroce
mais optimiste en général mais en ce qui
concerne cette activité d'argile type
l'industrie cette activité là je suis
triste bon je pense que votre probable
arrivée se fait dans un contexte
économique social culturel qui quand
même représente quelque chose de tout à
fait nouveau dans ce pays on est passé
d'une situation à une autre et même si
la reprise qu'on attend bien sûr viendra
un jour
de toute façon nous sommes entrés je
l'espère en tout cas
dans un monde nouveau quant au
comportement d'aider des gens quand tu
roules de l'état à certaines prises de
confiance sur des dossiers qui ont été
oubliés et donc la question c'est
comment vous arrivez
quel regard porté sur la programmation
actuelle moi je fais partie de ceux qui
est qui elle considère que c'est une
excellente radio 1
un bon groupe mais jeudi on pourra pas
rester comme ça qu'on est trop décalé
par rapport à des situations que nous
voyons new soul terrain les gens
n'écoutent plus les politiques et c'est
tout juste s'ils écoutent les syndicats
il ya une rupture considérable dans ce
pays qui se développent et les gens ne
sont pas disponibles pour écouter
un discours qui qu'on peut aménager un
peu à la marge
donc on a une vraie question politique
qui nous est posée à nous mais et qui
pose est évidemment à vous quelles que
soient les préjugés favorables que
commun sur ce groupe c'est radio et les
confronter je crois un défi immense et
donc la question c'est vous arrivez que
faire par rapport à la programmation
actuelle tout en gardant certaines
émissions mais peut-être en changeant
les contenus aussi ça c'est une je pense
une question très difficile qu'on peut
pas non plus régler d'un revers de main
peut-être qu'on peut en discuter que m'a
dit serge lagauche le jour où vous
serait officiellement place pour en
parler au fond j'ai une autre question
plus ou moins directement liés à cette
question là c'est bon escient un groupe
et à un groupe radio france puis un
groupe france télévisions est ce que ces
gens là travaillent ensemble ce qu'il ya
des synergies entre eux quelquefois
j'entends va france inter les annonces
sur ce que en présente un antenne 2 et
france 3 j'avoue que j'entends pas
souvent le linverse est ce que vous
pensez pas que deux grands groupes
publics comme cela pourrait avoir des
visions communes des stratégies communes
pour être plus efficace et notamment je
pense un sujet qui est d'actualité
puisque on a une élection européenne
dans quelques semaines
j'ai vu un sondage qui dit que 61% des
français ne connaissent pas les dates
encore et un déficit sur cette question
européenne qui reste quand même une des
grandes ambitions de ce pays on ne fera
rien dans ce pays si on ne passe pas par
l'europe l'europe est publié dans ce
pays complètement oublié
est-ce que
français vision radio france non pas
pour bien sur un contre mais je pense
surtout à moyen et long terme une
responsabilité immense dans
l'appréhension par les français de
l'europe grâce à des opérations que j'en
ai en tête certaine qu'on a commencé à
faire de partenariats avec d'autres pays
et d'autres radios mais est ce que vous
ne pensez pas que quand même là et on y
voit énorme affaire énorme affaire et
enfin dernière question plus technique
bon on a vu comment la publicité a
évolué à la télévision de votre côté
comment vous voyez elle la politique de
la publicité
j'essaie de répondre sans sortir du
cadre le sénateur de d'attribution qui
ne sont pas encore les miennes à vous le
comprenez bien en ce qui concerne la
situation économique et sociale du pays
c'est ce que ces deux le soin que
j'avais pris a évoqué dans mon propos
liminaire c'est à dire que il service
public est un c'est vraiment un lien
démocratique et vous avez sans doute
raison de dire que si on devrait
peut-être s'adapter aussi la situation
fallait les fabricants de programme et
pas seulement sur service public
d'ailleurs devraient s'adapter à la
situation que que traverse le pays moi
c'est une idée que 20 kg et qui est
difficile à mettre en place au fond
parce que quand vous avez une grille de
programme vous avez des producteurs vous
avez des salariés vous avez les
auditeurs vous avez des gens usa des
contrats vont très difficile de modifier
les choses et ça se fait jamais à coups
de hache sur une antenne mais je crois
que on peut les gens qui font ce métier
là sont apathiques en général tout même
s'il n'y ferais pas ce métier là ils
sont sensibles au courant bon mauvais
qu'ils passent sur une société et je
pense que j'ai pensé il ya quelques
semaines d'ailleurs bien avant que j'ai
aucune raison
me retrouver devant vous aujourd'hui
j'ai pensé que les radios de service
public devrait accompagner davantage ce
qui se passe il ya une information n'y a
pas que l'information vue d'un point de
vue politique ou économique a donné il
le faut ça c'est notre mission
d'éclairer le débat pour les électeurs
pour les français mais il ya aussi une
façon d'accompagner les français quand
ils sont quand ils sont dans l'ennui gvg
revient à france bleu là je pense que
c'est par exemple moi je pensais
beaucoup de services qu que des antennes
locales de proximité peuvent donner à
des gens qui sont qui sont dans
l'embarras et sa sauce on sent moins ça
à paris qu'ailleurs mais moi je suis pas
parisien donc je passe deux jours par
semaine dans ma région et je vois bien
que les discussions les conversations
les soucis sont pas toujours les mêmes
ou en tout cas au jeu peu comment dire
je peux lire sentir plus facilement dans
ma région et donc je pense que les gens
qui travaillent sur les stations de
france bleu sont préoccupés aussi par ça
il va falloir re justement redonner un
peu l'initiative aux gens qui sont sur
place peut-être est un peu décentralisés
les contenus en tout cas c'est une
impression après ça mérite de l'explorer
dans la réalité de des personnels de ces
de ses antennes à je pense aussi
monsieur le sénateur que dans les
périodes difficiles comme ça je sais pas
si vous avez noté mais la culture est un
est une espèce de sinon de refuge du
mois si peut-être j'ai vu je discute
beaucoup avec des écrits d'un parce que
c'était mon champ de
des gens qui fabriquent des films ou qui
joue au théâtre et on sent qu'il ya une
espèce de grande concentration en ce
moment des français là dessus alors il
faut pas les priver de ça non plus je
dis il faut il faut aussi les divertir
il faut aussi les intéresser à des
choses que peut être cette époque permet
d'offrir au fond c'est une réflexion
plus approfondie sur un certain nombre
de choses mais on n'est pas là pour
philosophes et bien sûr en ce qui
concerne un groupe france télévisions il
ya eu le rtf
on veut pas j'imagine remettre ça je
pense pas que ça avec des des qualités
bien que ça n'ait pas eu que des défauts
à et notamment sur le plan de sur plein
de la culture et je crois que la
différenciation des d activité a
bénéficié aux deux activités c'est à
dire que nous nous sommes très dédié à
la radio à mieux faire notre travail de
radio et les journaux télévisions ont
encore une fois ils ont une vie
différente puisque ne produisent pas ce
qu'ils fabriquent donc chacun chacun sa
façon d'alimenter les antennes mais mais
vous parliez par exemple des publicités
que moi aussi j'entends beaucoup sur les
antennes d'une radio france au bénéfice
de france télévisions j'ai encore
rarement linverse dont vous regardez ce
qui se passe là dedans mais mais j'ai vu
à quel point il était difficile de faire
des partenariats avec france et je vais
vous donner un exemple ce sont des
victoires de la musique par exemple
auquel je tenais beaucoup parce que ça
permettait des concerts en direct
gratuit enfin c'est vraiment très vivant
pour une antenne comme france inter et
il fallait se battre au couteau pour
avoir un partenariat pour juste avoir un
petit logo france inter en bas de
l'écran deux fois pendant la
retransmission de l'émission de victoire
la musique donc ça c'est une question
d'autorité aussi des patrons de groupes
les relations sont bonnes
à titre personnel avec les patrons de
ces groupes n'ont que je pense qu'il ya
à faire il ya des partenariats nouveaux
nouveau à faire et puis l'europe
c'est un serpent de mer pour les médias
c'est à dire qu'ils responsable de
l'ignorance entre guillemets relative ou
de ce désintérêt à propos de ce qui se
passe en europe
si j'étais producteur d'émissions
j'aurai une idée pour ça puisque c'est
si difficile puisqu'on s'est concentrée
sur la technique de l'europe la
technicité puisqu'on s'est intéressé à
la complexité finalement réglementaire
de l'europe
pourquoi on s'est pas intéressée aux
gens qu'ils qui vivent en europe
pourquoi on pourquoi on connaît tous de
gérard depardieu ça va on a peut-être un
peu l'indigestion j'aime beaucoup gérard
depardieu mais pourquoi on y répond
c'est pas umberto eco le connais un peu
peut-être qu'on pourrait connaître plus
être que ces gens pour incarner où il ya
bien en suède des gens magnifiques qui
écrit ce dépôt là où qu'ils font des
films est con con assez raide attirer à
nous peut être que ça ouvrirait aussi
quelques esprits c'est pas l'heure sais
pas ce qui va faire que les français
vont connaître la date des élections
européennes mais c'est parce que je suis
en train de dire mais au moins de ces
sur le temps que ces choses se font hors
on a du retard
moi je pense qu'il ya peut-être d'autres
biais quand quelque chose ne marche pas
pourtant les médias ont fait des efforts
sauce qui la connaissance du mécanisme
européen
moi j'ai décentralisée à strasbourg est
ravi que les balles conseil européen
donc ça n'a pas coûté un sou au
contribuable français si j'ose dire
on a fait toute une journée à strasbourg
parlement et ça a été formidable parce
que ça rendait la chose vivante mais
dont on sait que c'est pas c'est pas un
sujet facile mais il ya peut-être
d'autres biais justement les mulets le
bien culturel pour pour surprendre les
gens pour se dire tiens il ya sept
allemands la c1 européen voilà c'est je
ne réponds pas tout à fait à votre souci
mais on partage le souci
monsieur jack ralite vous en prie chers
collègues
oui serait d'abord vous dire que j'ai
beaucoup aimé quand vous avez dit que
vous voulez pas qu'une radio jeunes se
transforment en radio ghetto et pourquoi
j'ai été sensible cette façon de vous
exprimer c'est parce que actuellement
avec des études et des expertises ont
fait des tas de cible et on essaie de
faire pour chaque cible une réponse est
dans votre attitude sur ghetto et jeunes
s'est senti qu vous n'alliez pas dans le
genre de réponse que nous donne
aujourd'hui qui finalement m'est en
petits morceaux de société et finalement
à kas d'ailleurs j'ai noté que vous
utilisez plus le mot pluralisme que
diversité et ça ça me ravit
parce que au nom de la diversité qui en
général chosifie les choses vous êtes
divers rester le et on vous respecte
comme ça d'accord le pluralisme est plus
dynamique
il oblige ce que l'homme cherche nomme
il oblige être un bal hier quoi et ça
c'est une très grande question qui n'est
pas suffisamment régler des sports
et que g110 constituait pour vous une
sorte de combustible est de ceux là
à cela je suis très très sensible tout
enfermement de quelque nature qu'ils
soient tous qui dit s'est achevée celui
là il tourne quelque part le dos à une
démocratie
or la presse la radio la télévision
c'est une dimension structurante de la
démocratie comment les des législateurs
on a un petit peu peut-être on est
orgueilleux en fait c'est une tâche par
les autres avec la sanction de élections
à protéger l'espace public comme espace
où les gens se trouvent et se retrouvent
et se reconnaissent et se reconnaissent
voyez par exemple bon ben si vous gaver
été envisagée j'aurais presque aimé y
ait deux trois personnes
parce que je suis plus sensible aux
différentiels comme dit lévi-strauss cas
la différence plus d'avoir plus les
différences sont indifférentes aux
différences pas dit que le différentiel
chercheuse qui fait qu'on est à l'homme
est forcément on est un peu et beaucoup
comme les autres mais qu'on a une une
façon particulière d'aborder et ça ça
beau bouquet c'est pas des oeillets
toutes les couleurs c'est toutes les
fleurs alors je voulais dire ça parce
que j'ai été touché et je trouve qu'il
faut avancer dans ce sens là contre les
les habitudes sclérosante et pour ça
rien de mieux que de choisir nina coup
de france l'élan du pluralisme l'odeur
de la création quoi sont des mots colère
de tous les jours mais les gens et
compagne ses volants les gens c est qu
on prenne
j'ajoute aussi la faculté d'irrespect
c'est une belle expression de vaillants
la faculté irrespect bon c'est un petit
peu ce que je voulais dire j'ai
l'impression de rentrer dans la
discussion d'un cahier farce je me
différencie tour mais j'aime aussi des
différences mais et un différentiel
donc je voulais dire ça c'est peut-être
la chose essentielle que je voulais que
je voulais dire parce que j'en ai un peu
assez de des gens qui qui finalement
sont sont des engrais parce que trop
ancrées oui ça peut voilà une chose que
je voulais vous dire bon par ailleurs
ben je vous connais je vous ai écoutés
comme beaucoup d'entre nous ca y est
bête de dire ça mais vous êtes un bon
jour à nice puisqu'on à parler le métier
autant dire voilà voilà
alors bien évidemment j'aime pas la
façon dont il a été choisi de faire les
choses se trouve ça nul part ailleurs je
trouve que c'est une politique d'ancien
régime je parle de deux façons de faire
mais ça c'est pas ça qui il doit être le
tamis pour vous vous juger quoi
voilà voilà en fait j'aime pas la
pratique qui fait qu'on a double mais
j'aime bien dire je choisis pour mais
adoubée
oui
voilà je peux jouer 10 je reste si
monsieur sénateurs je vous connais je
voulais vous est ce que je sais que vous
êtes un homme très ouvert
donc je voulais vous citez un patron
d'entreprise privée la pop aux deux
pluralité de diversité c'est monsieur
rigaud qui a longtemps régné sur le
monde magique et merveilleux d'rtl la
grande époque d'rtl
il m'avait expliqué cette notion
pluralisme
il m'avait dit voilà ce qu'est ce qu'un
qu'est ce qu'une belle radio je sais pas
s'il faisait référence à sa propre radio
d'ailleurs les musées c'est la radio
d'un honnête homme
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'un honnête
homme ça monsieur qui pourrait
s'intéresser à la musique qui
connaîtraient pas le théâtre mais quel
mois n'entendent parler ça vire en tête
envie d'aller au théâtre qui aurait
besoin d'informations pour être un
citoyen enfin donc comment être citoyen
si on n'est pas informé et il est même
le football
il adore la musique pas toutes les
musiques mais on lui offre tout à
variété de ce qui peut et on le respecte
et si vous faites tout ça vous avez une
belle radio et un homme un homme un
honnête homme au sens que vous voudrez
donner à l'expression mais j'avais
trouvé que c'était une belle définition
de la radio
allez-y allez j'y vois pas vous leur
faire aimer les lois ou de 80,3 du point
de vue de la représentativité des
personnels elle donne des possibilités
intéressantes
c'est à dire qu'ils sont un nombre
suffisant pour être au moins entendu en
tout cas dignement reconnu si vous êtes
choisis si vous travaillez dans le
convention collective et tout ça puisque
je vous conseille de relire les lois
auroux non mais c'est vrai parce que et
voilà on est dans une société où les
sens on regarde en chiens de faïence et
mais des fois on regarde en chiens de
faïence parce que j'en garde dans la
dernier dans la loi sur l'audiovisuel
ils seront deux faits mort ou d'ici sont
5 5 on les quelqu'un deux on est invité
et il ya quelque chose à faire et dans
ces choses comme son la radio et la
télévision qui nous appartiennent à tous
à tous
là c'est tout je m'arrête je donne tout
de suite la parole à monsieur noack et
ensuite à monsieur bell oui bon deux
bords je partage l'avis exprimé par
certains collègues sur le côté un peu
irréel un peu surréaliste de la
procédure de désignation et y compris
sur le rôle que l'on entend nous faire
jouer nous parlementaires à ce stade de
la désignation il mais la première
question monsieur s vous avez quand on
regarde votre parcours vos
responsabilités vos préoccupations vos
pôles d'intérêt vous avez une relation
forte avec les états unis et je crois
que vous aviez vais sérieusement étudiée
effectivement le paysage audiovisuel
américain notamment le paysage
radiophonique dont je voudrais savoir
quelle quelle leçon quels enseignements
vous pensez tirer de cette expérience
l'a notamment ce qui concerne le
traitement de l'information parce que
c'est vrai vous avez à juste titre
insisté à plusieurs reprises sur la
notion de service public la déontologie
du métier etc et dont je voudrais savoir
effectivement comment vous entendez vous
inspiré demain de ce que vous avez
rencontrés là-bas et la deuxième
question bon nous sommes des des
parlementaires mais nous sommes tous en
même temps des élus locaux des élus
territoriaux et donc nous sommes très
attachés à tout le réseau de radio
france est à dire à france bleu mais
force est de constater que sur le
terrain depuis plusieurs années il ya eu
une sorte de de restriction de réduction
de toute la partie locale je dirais deux
de ses radios là notamment en ce qui
concerne la programmation l'information
les équipes de journalistes les équipes
d'animateurs et c est dans le futur
contrat d'objectifs et de moyens on
souhaiterait effectivement que ce soit
l'une de vos préoccupations majeures
demain que de donner un coup d'arrêt à
ce désengagement la successeure je
commençais par france bleu si si vous le
permettez je suis je ne suis pas en
position de critiquer le travail des
gens je suis pas dans cette maison donc
j'ai juste un avis extérieur pour
l'instant je pense que vous le
comprendrez ce jeudi je suis simplement
étonné de temps en temps de ce que vous
évoquez c'est à dire que je pense qu'une
radio une station locale doit être au
plus près de son pays et c'est vrai
qu'il ya des décrochages nationaux que
je trouve d'ailleurs parfois bizarres
sur plan des horaires je me tiens moi
qui connaît bien la vie de région s'est
pas mais heureuse pas mes horaires de
vie quoi donc je pense qu'il faut voir
des choses comme ça bien évidemment les
eu un souci d'économie manifeste je vais
pas critiquer cet aspect du dossier que
je ne connais pas suffisamment
d'ailleurs mais je pense que oui il y
fort et harmoniser quelque chose par là
enfin la vocation durable
l'essentiel des stations de france bleu
c'est la proximité c'est la vie
c'est la vie locale donc je pense qu'il
faudrait aménager un certain de choses
c'est vrai aussi niveau de la
programmation musicale d'ailleurs c'est
vrai certains certes un autre niveau
donc c'est un souci que je partage et je
vous promets que le contrat d'objectifs
et de moyens traitera peut-être pas
votre entière satisfaction mais mais
cette question là si on parle de
l'expérience américaine j'ai peur qu'on
ait soit très longtemps mais je vous en
dit un petit mot tout de même parce que
mais c'est un peu perso nation ça je
vais pas vous faire perdre votre temps
mais j'ai eu deux époques dans ma vie de
journaliste j'ai commencé à 17 ans en
france et je souhaitais quitter ce
métier vers la trentaine enfin peu avant
d'avoir 30 ans parce que j'aimais trop
ce métier pour la pratique telle que je
la connaissais tels que j'ai exercées en
france quelques ça ne dérangeait quelque
part puis je suis allé aux états unis en
1980 j'y suis resté dix ans et ça marc
mariée avec mon métier il ya tous les
défauts du mass médias de l'industrie
pour le coup des médias mais il ya aussi
quelques magnifiques qualité éthique du
métier de journaliste
d'ailleurs il était tellement belle
qu'elle se sont effondrés au moment de
l'invasion de l'irak
c'était une leçon alors pour le coup
philosophique et politique pour pour moi
et pour plein d'autres gens c'est à dire
que c'est fragile tout ça c'est fragile
c'était la plus belle écurie j'en alice
ti que du monde les états unis dans les
années 70 et 80 est un peu après et ça
s'est écroulé en très peu de temps il a
suffi d'une invasion de l'irak pour que
chacun se couvrent se cache ne veulent
plus voir la réalité finit sperme en
tire un peu l'opinion c'est quand même
un des leades démocratie grave dans ce
pays que j'adore et que je respecte donc
au moins
moi ça m'a donné une structure mentale
pour exercer mon métier j'ai adoré ces
années américaines avec tous les défauts
seulement si je défends en tant que
service public c'est que la part du
service public aux états unis lé pa
épaisse
c'est celle qui marche le mieux la radio
publique la haine encarnacion kuyt radio
s'est pour sa part d'audience aucun
groupe de radio france mais c'est une
seule antenne très associé à internet
d'ailleurs
et ça marche du feu de dieu je veux dire
c'est une réussite de service public
c'est pas le service public à la
française c'est à dire gagne part de
subvention de l'état qui s'est rabougri
d'ailleurs et puis une part de donation
des des citoyens mais c'est une c'est
une très belle chose mais il ya tout le
reste qui est privé qui se porte pas si
mal
le taux de crédit le taux de confiance
et un peu affaissé et l'audience de la
radio mais cette dispense en quelques
années
alors monsieur bel est ensuite madame
laborde avec les questions sont
nombreuses
oui donc je vais essayer d'être bref ce
président su s vous vous l'avez compris
de ce côté ci même si c'est pas
totalement exhaustif ne sommes pas très
à l'aise après midi dans cet entretien
disant qu'on aurait peut-être aimé vous
recevoir dans des conditions différentes
donc sont partagées par des sentiments
ambivalents
je vais pas faire trop lent là dessus
j'ai pas vous demander ce que vous
pensez de la nouvelle manière de
désigner le patron de radio france vous
êtes vraiment le plus mal placé vous
l'avez dit pourrait pour répondre à ce
genre de question mais vous comprendrez
également quelle position peut être dit
celle des sénateurs qui disons comme
jack ralite et serge lagauche quelques
autres sens tout de même un peu troublé
par l'exercice que l'on nous propose
aujourd'hui alors simplement une
question pour satisfaire ma curiosité
lors des contacts vous avez pu avoir qui
disent on était à l'origine de la
proposition de désignation est ce que il
a été question d'un binôme de entendait
que vous pourriez formé avec le futur
patron de france inter où est ce que ce
sont vraiment des élucubrations de
journaliste en deux mots ou est-ce que
vous allez nous présenter une équipe à
deux où est ce qu'on vous a proposé de
le faire voilà je passe il pourrait
répondre à cette question si je peux
répondre à toutes vos questions le
sénateur l'apave préliminaire mot sur
sénateurs je sais pas c'est bien je vous
dis je vais pas commenter cette fois
c'est vous qui voter les lois c'est pas
moi c'est jeu voilà je suis là devant
vous et donc vous comprenez les limites
de l'exercice aussi pour moi mais ya pas
eu de préliminaires et quant à l'homme
que vous évoquez mes idées sont à moi à
aucun moment avec le président russe
n'est pas et du contenu des antennes ou
déjà est-ce que ça répond quelque part à
votre interrogation
j'ajouterais même que j'ai été surpris
je veux pas aller plus loin dans je sais
que ça se fait mais moi c'est pas mon
éducation
je nous réparons pour la confidentialité
d'un entretien avec le président
république
j'ajoute que j'ai tendance quelles que
soient les valeurs des uns et les autres
j'ai tendance à faire confiance
absolument la présidence à la parole
d'un président de la république j'ai été
élevé comme ça je finirai comme ça je ne
suis pas naïf
merci donc bon vous êtes journaliste
vous avez été présentateur de
différentes émissions directeur de
france inter est aujourd'hui moi ce que
j'aimerais savoir si par rapport à votre
nomination est un cahier des charges
imposé on va dire quel espace de liberté
avez-vous pensez vous avoir pour devenir
donc président de radio france est
dirigée avec quand même
enfin moi je n'arrive pas à situer tout
à fait entre le cahier des charges
l'espace de liberté
voilà c'est en fait c'est pas un
entretien que nous vous en passer
puisque nous avons un choix ou un non
choix pour vous désignez mais qu'est ce
qu'ils feraient voilà si on était en
entretien d'embauché
quelles qualités moi j'ai envie
d'entendre quel est votre espace de
liberté quelle est votre idée forte à
vous qui vous appartient à vous voilà
qui donne envie de m oui ou non puisque
c'est le choix ou le non choix que j'ai
voilà ma modestie souffrirait cordy roma
je vais essayer d'aborder le problème un
peu différemment et je ne dirai si je
suis dans le ligne le droit fil de votre
e de votre interrogation mais j'ai
depuis deux mois ou un mois et demi lui
ici et là que rien ne pouvait me
préparer à cette fonction puisque je
n'étais pas gestionnaire puisque voilà
quand j'ai eu l'impression qu'il y avait
deux catégories de gens y avait ce qui
par
je sais pas par quoi d'ailleurs enfin
j'ai une petite idée mais peuvent être
gestionnaire d'une grande entreprise
publique et puis il ya ceux comme les
journalistes ou qui sont pas faits pour
jeu c'est pas ma notion de
de la vie en général enfin tout court
moi je dirige et moi même et puis oui et
puis un jour j'ai dirigé une rédaction
de 120 journalistes
puis un jour j'ai dirigé 453 personnes
d'une grande antenne publique et j'ai
toujours dû des budgets impeccable je
suis battu pour mon équilibre j'ai
toujours fait en sorte que les audiences
montre j'ai fait j'ai fait ce qu'un chef
d'entreprise fait quoi alors
effectivement je n'ai jamais été
président de radio france n'est jamais
dirigé une entreprise avec de tels
dossiers avec un chantier de plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros à venir
une numérisation route surprend la
diffusion de développement internet qui
sont compliqués enfin qui est supposé
investissements j'ai jamais j'ai jamais
réécrit une convention collective pour
une entreprise de cette dimension
mais radio france est plein de talent
c'est plein de gens qui sont ces plein
de gens qui travaillent en ce moment qui
travaille bien
kiki à ma pdg n'est pas tout seul c'est
pas un homme seul roland c'est une
catastrophe
je lis il ya 4500 talent radio france
plus ou moins exploité plus ou moins
mobilisé plus voilà à quoi donc c'est
très difficile pour moi de vous dire bah
voila je suis meilleur patron possible
pour aller aux france vu justement le
mode de désignation c'est vrai que ça se
passe pas comme ça mais c'est pas moi
qui ai choisi d'informer et je ne vais
pas m'en plains pas mais moi je veux pas
être hypocrite je suis ravi de là devant
vous pour essayer de vous dire que si
vous faisiez confiance je serai le
meilleur patron de radio-france possible
d'ailleurs vous ne verrez personne dans
cette enceinte dans les mêmes
circonstances vous dire le contraire
vous dira je suis pas sûr de ça ou de
saout ça c'est l' aventure de la vie
mais encore une fois moi je crois radio
france qui nourrissent que je connais
bien du sol au plafond
j'ai même de la cave à des endroits où
personne ne va jamais je connais les
métiers de radio france je connais les
gens je connais
on a une relation ensemble ça veut pas
dire que la relation est rose à pdg
assume ses responsabilités c'est quelque
chose aussi qui est important à vous
dire c'est que quand on pense ce genre
de fonction quand on accepte de de
postuler à 10 ans de fonction quel que
soit le mode de désignation on assume
ses responsabilités et les gens de radio
france me connaissent pour cette qualité
là si j'en ai une ça répond à ma
question sur vos tombes d'entente que
vous soyez ravis
monsieur mme oda a demandé la parole
si michel président us
je veux dire que c'est agréable
d'entendre votre voix dans la mesure où
pendant toute la période où les périodes
nous avons eu l'occasion de nous
entendre en particulier à france inter
vous faites déjà partie d'une histoire
l'histoire de cette radio et c'est ce
que comme ça déjà été exprimée mais je
dirais peut-être une autre façon
permettez moi à mon tour de venir nous
met un peu et moi aussi un peu mal à
l'aise
vous avez dit tout à l'heure d'entrer
quand on vous a posé la question je me
suis la gauche vous appelez la question
êtes vous angoissez ne collectent le
résultat des votes
ils vont avoir lieu à cette commission
et à celle de l'assemblée nationale vous
avez répondu oui
permettez moi de vous dire en toute
franchise que je pense vous êtes apte à
trop fins connaisseurs de la vie et de
la vie politique française pour savoir
que vous ne risquez pas être l'objet
d'une crise politique majeure en france
qui s'essaie d'une rupture entre le
président de la république et sa
majorité parlementaire
donc ne soyez pas angoissé tout va se
passer très bien j'en suis convaincu
ceci étant dit il est temps ça ou je
vous disais que je suis un peu mal à
l'aise parce que j'évoquais jean luc
hess journalistes mais la question qui
nous est posée et la loi d'ailleurs qui
a été votée nous amène effectivement à
répondre non pas la question de savoir
est ce que monsieur jean luc hess où
paraît être un bon et un mauvais journal
ou un mauvais journaliste sommes
capables d'assumer les fonctions de
président de radio france
la question qui nous est posée c'est est
ce que vous êtes d'accord ou pas avec le
choix du président de la république
j'aurais aimé moi pouvoir me déterminer
par rapport à la question posée en
premier je suis très mal à l'aise pour
m'exprimer
sachant que ce n'est pas cette question
là qui nous est posée mais c'est la
deuxième fois que vous viviez avec nous
aussi on aura donc l'occasion de se
revoir mais il n'empêche que c'est quand
même bien ce tas qui sera la conclusion
de ce vote et malheureusement nous ne
pourrons pas dire tout bien ou tour mag
mais tout bientôt profonde ou simplement
je voudrais vous poser une une simple
question vous allez donc prendre la
responsabilité d'une grande maison radio
france c'est par un quiz et c'est très
sérieux
si je disais à l'heure actuelle quel est
le point fort sur lequel vous pensez
pouvoir compter sur cette maison telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui et son point
faible sur lequel vous vous dites là
c'est là que je vais avoir du boulot
voilà la question que je souhaiterais
beaucoup que je souhaitais vous posez je
peux faire un tout petit commentaire sur
votre propos d'entrée tout de même sur
l'angoissé jose en paix parce que je ne
sais pas quel sera évidemment le
résultat du vote des parlementaires mais
imaginons qu'il me soit favorable qui ne
me soit pas défavorables j'aurai à faire
à vous j'aurai à faire un ministère de
la culture j'aurai à faire à la ddm j
aurais offert au csa j'ai besoin de
convaincre
quel que soit le mode de désignation
j'ai besoin que vous me regardiez si le
processus de désignation va jusqu'à son
terme en ce qui me concerne que vous ne
regardez comme un professionnel qui
dirige une grande entreprise de service
public
donc j'ai besoin de votre confiance
quelles que soient les réserves que vous
avez très bien souligné que je comme une
fois je n'ai pas de commentaires à faire
là-dessus mais c'est ça qui m'angoisse
au fond c'est bien évidemment le
résultat à l'arrivée mais c'est des
années à venir et la responsabilité qui
m'incombe ray et des fera si les choses
se passent dans un sens qui m'est
favorable
il faudra que vous ayez un regard sur
moi qui soit celui d'un chef
d'entreprise ce le regard coalition un
chef d'entreprise et qui utilisent
l'argent public c'est à dire que ça
c'est une responsabilité clim qui
m'angoisse qui me ravit mais qui
m'angoisse aussi est votre regard
m'importe infiniment au delà de la loi
sur laquelle je n'ai absolument pas de
commentaire à faire sur le mode de
désignation est un des points forts de
la maison moi je vous dis le point fort
de la maison c'est le personnage ne
l'annoncé pas démagogique
c'est que tout se fait tout tout est
produit radio france par le personnel
encore une fois on parlait de france
télévisions tout à l'heure français
vision doit produire en direct 10% de
ses contenus nous c'est 100% et donc
quelles que soient les vicissitudes de
l'existence cette entreprise a toujours
innové a toujours s'est toujours adapté
ça râle c'est dans la nature nos métiers
au 6 mai mais voilà le point fait de
l'entreprise pour l'instant pour moi
c'est le chantier de réhabilitation
c'est à dire que je ne connais pas ce
dossier je n'ai pas accès je n'ai pas eu
accès et donc ça je sais que ça
conditionne tout pour les années à venir
au delà des envies qu'on peut avoir de
l'imagination qu'on peut avoir
au delà de l'énergie qu'on peut mettre
dans cette belle machine
c'est là que ça se passe si les choses
se passent bien sûr sur cet immense
chantier coûteux est nécessaire cette
maison poids prendre son plein régime
soit pas dire vitesse de croisière mais
son plein régime
bien et chers collègues je crois qu'ils
ont soumis monsieur s à de très
nombreuses questions et s'est efforcée
d'y d'y répondre j'en aurais peut-être
une ou 2 a vous a ajouté estimez vous
monsieur est ce que
radio france doit prendre sa part à la
politique francophone de notre pays il
était inscrit dans le contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens 2006-2009 de
radio france qui doit y avoir un
renforcement des liens entre radio
france et rfi par exemple comment voyez
vous les rapports entre radio france et
rfi vous intéresserez vous aussi à ce
que représentent ces français de
l'étranger pour qui la radio est un
élément également très important et puis
si je m'attache à la francophonie tout
le monde le sait dans cette commission
j'ai aussi beaucoup de respect pour
toutes les langues y compris nos langues
régionales
alors je vais vous demander si vous
envisagez peut-être de voir dans quelle
mesure
france bleu pour accorder une place peut
être un peu plus importante à nos
langues régionales
voilà ça sur les quais on voulait vous
posez en vous disant aussi et puisque
son entre nous on fait un petit
commentaire sur l'exercice auquel nous
nous livrons que dans cette commission
qui est aussi la commission de la
communication
nous aurons bien évidemment l'intention
de recevoir le futur président de radio
france
très régulièrement de donner notre
sentiment sur les contrats d'objectifs
et de moyens et donc pour nous le
rapport avec le future prison de radio
france n'est pas simplement une occasion
de se rencontrer quand il n'est pas
encore en fonction mais tout au long et
à la suite des choses de poursuivre avec
avec vous le dialogue que doit avoir
nécessairement la représentation
nationale avec leurs responsables en
charge de la radio publique dans notre
pays le président je vais forcer de
répondre sur ce sur un des dossiers que
je connais moins bien que l'autre en ce
qui concerne les relations et guéret
fils
il me semble on parlait tout à l'heure à
outrance et vision de coopération entre
autres des organismes publics ça me
semble évident d'ailleurs je veux dire
que c'est qu'à des jeunes
puis bien des années là je parle
d'informations parce que on a toujours
sollicité sans aucune réserve les les
gens et ce de rfi pour nos
correspondances donc je pense qu'il faut
évidemment vivre même si les statuts ont
changé afin ou sont en train de se
modifier sensiblement je pense que
effectivement il faut établir ce lien là
en ce qui concerne la francophonie jeu
j'écoute les antennes je dois
reconnaître qu'un qu'un effort a été
fait sur sur france inter je pense
notamment une émission littéraire sur la
sur la francophonie donc est-ce que
c'est suffisant sûrement pas mais je
pense que il ya une vraie nouvelle
association et puis j'ai eu l'occasion
mais au fil des années de ne fréquenter
donc mes collègues des radios des radios
publiques francophones
encore une fois la bonne volonté et
reste à avoir à imaginer des formules
qui soit vraiment efficace et pas
simplement verbal et puis en ce qui
concerne les langues régionales je vous
avoue que je que je regarde dans ce
dossier de france besoin on peut faire à
quel endroit peut le faire sous quelle
forme et quelle service quel service
public ça je suis bien convaincu que si
c'est un souci pour vous c'est qu'une
question existe et que les questions
doivent apporter des réponses bien je
remercie mes chers collègues
nous allons en remercions monsieur est
d'avoir répondu à nos questions nous
allons lui demander maintenant de nous
laisser procédé on vote mais vous pouvez
rester dans la maison dès que le
résultat dès que nous aurons penser à
notre sport
jean programme avec le résultat et vous
vous la communiquerons immédiatement en
tout cas je veux pas vraiment joué vous
je pense qu'il n'est question de faire
mourir personne mon cher collègue
je voulais simplement vous remercie pour
votre courtoisie et la qualité de nos
interventions et vos questions j'y
allais je le dis sincèrement je remercie
beaucoup